the number of Americans dying from drug
overdoses is dramatically increasing the
CDC estimates overdoses killed more than
72,000 people last year it has become
the leading cause of death for Americans
under the age of 50 we told you
yesterday about news anchor Angela
Kenickie of our CBS affiliate Kelo in
South Dakota she has covered the
overdose crisis for about ten years now
but she lost her own daughter to the
opioid epidemic just four months ago
Kenickie returned to work this week and
she says she felt an obligation to share
her very personal story with her viewers
the opioid epidemic has hit home in a
tragic and devastating way for me
personally on May 16th my 21 year old
daughter Emily died of an overdose
Angela Kenickie spoke to her daughter
for the last time on Mother's Day
[Music]
Emily struggled with addiction for more
than a year Angela tried to get her
treatment but says she was too late I
got a frantic call from her dad saying I
think Emily's od'd you need to get over
here right now I can't even describe to
you what it's like to hear those words
Emily overdosed on the opioid fentanyl
in May Angela spoke about her daughter's
fight at her funeral before her
addiction crossed for real after a few
months off until the return to the
newsdesk to share her story in hopes of
saving lives Angela is one of the
strongest women I have ever met news
director Beth Jensen said she knew
Angela's story would resonate the way
she told that story was so authentic it
is already making a difference and this
crusade evangelist is now crusade of the
stations and it's going to be in our DNA
for a long time
Angela Kenickie wants to help erase the
stigma around addiction she joins us now
and Angela thank you so much because I'm
so sorry you're here at the table for
this reason and I wonder as a local news
anchor why you decided that you were
going to share it so publicly was it a
struggle for you to make this
you know I took a few months off just to
cut cope with what had happened to me
and I thought I can less let this loss
this devastation destroy me or I can do
something about it
and over the course of my career I have
asked so many parents to talk to me and
just people in general who are grieving
who have had horrible tragic things
happen to them as you all do and I
thought I have to talk about it I have
an obligation to talk about it my number
one reason for talking about it is to
erase the stigma that is surrounding
addiction especially the use of heroin
opioids who had no idea she was using
heroin this was what I marvel at because
you said you all were close you knew she
had had some drug issues you said with
marijuana but you an investigative
reporter had no idea that she was using
heroin
it was the most shocking thing doing
needles mm-hmm a middle-class kid
privileged you know all these
opportunities and things like that and
it's hard to explain addiction it's hard
to understand my child ran out of the
doctor's office once when she was going
to get a shot so I never would have
dreamed that but because it's hit home
in such a an awful devastating way I
just feel so compelled to let everybody
know what happened to my daughter
can happen to you can happen to your
child well you all have children at this
yeah what was she just so good at hiding
it from you how was she able how were
you able not to know that she was on
heroin also she's an adult child 21
years old not living at home I thought
she was on something and I and I don't
consider myself a naive person I worked
in the news business for a long time
I've covered a lot of these stories but
she was able to hide this from me very
well and I think as a child you don't
want your parents to be ashamed of you
and there is so much shame that goes
along with this you don't want to
disappoint your parents and and and I
had to walk a very fine line between
trying to help her trying to talk to her
and alienating her are pushing her away
so I was always trying to approach it
with love and we were working to get her
help I just didn't get there on time
his own when you looked at had looked
back and have talked to other parents
have you found is there a you what have
you found that might have been either a
gateway or is there something that or is
it a mystery she was attracted to the
drug culture I think as a mineral later
teen years the peers I think as parents
you know we think we can isolate or
insulate our children from these kinds
of things we do all kinds of things to
try to protect them but after a certain
point parents don't have as much
influence and peers have a lot more more
toys and you know your kid gets in they
so cliche but with the wrong crowd or
the wrong people and maybe they have a
tendency toward that kind of thing an
addictive gene an addictive personality
and and it just snowballs and it's
indiscriminate and you said that you
spent so many times talking to families
that have suffered through this and you
went from asking why me - why not me and
that's something that families across
the country are asking themselves as
well talk about the stigma of going from
why me - why not me well as a reporter
it's always somebody else that I'm
reporting on it's always somebody else's
tragedy or triumph or whatever that may
be and talk about reporting you were
interviewing women who had lost their
children from drug overdose the day you
found out your daughter died I was I was
working on a story on the opioid
epidemic on overdoses and Good Samaritan
laws in our state and I spoke to three
parents on that day I knew my daughter
had a problem on that day we were
planning an intervention I just didn't
know what it was she was using mm-hmm
and I just think we need so much more
awareness we need so much more instead
of judgment compassion and I'm trying to
do what I can to make changes in my own
community back home to get people the
help that they need and that's really
all really I can do with this it's so
important it's so important and your
advice is if you suspect get in there
and say something because you said you
were planning an intervention you were
too late trust me unless a mr. Veeck
yeah trust your instincts they very
seldom fail you Angela thank you so much
I'm so sorry your vote you're here under
these circumstances but really glad to
meet you